Continuing in the book of purification
in the chapters of
regarding bathing al-ghusl.
The author
after giving the bare minimum of ghusl,
the two pillars ghusl, identifying them,
and then
giving us the fullest version of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam's
ghusl in the most comprehensive
He then gives us some
other additional details
that are commonly
unknown
or are commonly misunderstood.
He says
[Silence]
The first point here is that
it is not obligatory for a woman to take
her braids out
to bathe for janabah.
And we've mentioned this before, but
here the author mentions it with its
detailed evidence cited
that ghusl of janabah
it is not obligatory for a woman to take
her braids out to bathe for ghusl
janabah. And it is only obligatory
upon her to take her braids out
And it is only obligatory for her to
take her braids out
for ghusl
after her cycle, ghusl after postpartum.
And And the wisdom behind this is very
obvious. And that is that one is far
more frequent than the other, or perhaps
more frequent than the other.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us a
general description of the rulings. Wa
ma ja'ala alaykum fid-dini min
He cites then a narration on the
authority of Salamah.
She says, "I said, 'O Messenger of
Allah, indeed I am a woman who likes to
tighten her braids very tight.
If is it Do I need to take my braids out
every time I bathe for janabah?" He
said, "No.
It is enough for you to merely pour the
water on your head three times, and then
to pour the water on the remainder of
your body, and you will hence be
purified."
[Silence]
Asma is the older sister, one of the
older sisters of Aisha radiyallahu anha,
and they have different mothers. Asma's
mother is was a mushrikah, a non-Muslim,
from Quraysh.
Details vary on
what happened to her, whether she
accepted Islam or not. However,
Aisha's mother did accept Islam.
And so
Aisha mentions that Asma, her sister,
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam regarding the rulings on
bathing after menstrual cycle.
[Silence]
What's throwing me off of is in this
here they have the shed down on the
wrong letter. And every time I hit it's
tripping over the same piece of
furniture every time.
[Arabic recitation]
tongue twister. So, in this
narration, Aisha
she mentions that her sister Asma asked
the Prophet
regarding the
the description or the details
of bathing after her menstrual cycle.
And so,
this here tells us that not only did the
companions understand that there is
somewhat of a difference between the
menstrual cycle bathing a post menstrual
bathing and a janaba bathing. So, she
asked and so the Prophet
described to her that she is to take
water and put sidr in it. Remember sidr
we talked about it?
It's a type of leaf from a tree in the
desert and this is their soap back then,
right? It has cleaning properties in its
sap. And so, the Prophet
said she should take water and take sidr
and purify herself.
Now, notice how he says and clean
herself and purify herself. Meaning
what? Meaning her lady parts. And then,
she is to pour the water onto her head
and to work the water deeply into the
roots of her hair to ensure that the
water has reached her scalp entirely.
Now, this is very different than
what he told Salama with respect to the
of janaba, correct? And then he said
and then she is to take
She is to take a
a loofah kind of they used to
use the
if you ever notice a date palm
between the bark and the actual meats of
the tree
the base of the tree, right?
There's
a very squishy kind of
almost like
insulation there. If you take it, it's
it's almost cotton that comes out
which is very rough. They used to use
this for all kinds of things. One of the
things they used it for was to clean and
scrub. And there were other things that
they used for this, but today we use the
same texture, but we use it made out of
plastic usually or something of the
sort. So, he mentions to take a rag or
to take some
piece of fabric and to put musk or
perfume and to perfume herself and to
purify herself. And so,
Asma, she didn't really understand
exactly and she wanted to make sure that
she was getting it right. So, she said,
"How does she purify herself?" So, the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
response was
Subhanallah, purify herself. he
doesn't want to spell it out. She is a
female, he is a male, right? And so, the
other women explained to her out of
his presence. And she asked him about
ghusl of janabah. And he didn't say,
"Well, it's the same thing." If it was
the same thing, he would have just
responded, "Ghusl al-janabah is like
what I just told you."
So, it isn't the same exact thing in the
sense that it is not as stringent as the
ghusl or the post-menstrual ghusl. So,
he says, "She is to take the water and
to purify herself and to purify herself
well
and then she is to pour the water onto
her head and scrub
to get the water or work the water to
her scalp and then to pour the water on
the rest of herself." So, the post-
menstrual
ghusl is more intensive. It is involving
other cleaning agents as well and a
woman must take out her braids. A woman
must take out her braids. But for
janabah, she does not have to take out
her braids and the same goes for a man.
He does not have to take out
his braids for janabah.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
is is that for janabah
he mentions here the female, the woman,
not having to take her braids out for
janabah. And this obviously is very much
for men and women. There's no difference
in this type of ghusl. What goes for
one goes for the other because they both
have to bathe. However, there is a
difference between that and the
strictness in one someone taking out the
braids for post-menstrual
ghusl. And I think that that is very
clear.
[Arabic recitation]